be back at the world economic forum
and indeed ladies and gentlemen
i'm glad to be here with you today
so
there is one question that is lingering
out there since the start of the
pandemic
and it also includes what you have said
as the introduction clause
the question are our democracy strong
and fast enough
to face the incredible challenge of
covet 19
can democracies deliver
well i have no doubt
the pandemic has not only demonstrated
our democracy's ability to act
it has also shown that democracies
are the more powerful
the more resilient
and the more sustainable form of
government
i know of course that we have not
conquered covet 19 yet
if we are on our way to finally end this
pandemic
it is because we have mrna vaccines
developed by european scientists and
this
is thanks to our values
that these scientific breakthroughs have
been possible values
such as liberty of research
freedom of science
and the independent choices for
investors
and all of this means having the
vaccines that we are much better
equipped today
to fight this virus than two years ago
let me give you some facts
europe has delivered a total of over 1.2
billion doses of vaccines to its
citizens
now over 80 percent of adults
in europe are double vaccinated
but what is even more important
we are the only region in the world
that has continued to export or donate
to other countries from the beginning
and throughout the whole pandemic
a total of 1.6 billion doses made in
europe
have been delivered to 150 countries
and with industry producing more than
300 million doses of vaccine every month
in europe
there will be more to come
so these simple facts show
that we can trust in democracy to
deliver
and this word trust
has always been a thread
that runs through all editions of the
world economic forum
davos has always been about building
trust among leaders
most importantly
earning the trust of future generations
with responsible leadership
this year
like never before
trust is the most valuable currency
when we speak about the state of the
world
trust in science and vaccines
can make a difference between life and
death
trust among countries can tilt the
balance of international affairs
towards cooperation
instead of conflict
trust in functioning societies based on
the rule of law
channels higher levels of long-term
private investment
giving these societies an edge over
competitors
and this trust
is also essential to all of europe's
main ambitions
trust as you said
klaus is essential for citizens to
embrace the green and digital
transformation
or to attract young talents
the point is
that the recovery be it in europe or
globally
can only be built on trust and
confidence
and this is what i want to talk about
today
in the economic and financial crisis a
decade ago
member states in the european union
did not entrust the european level with
finding a european solution
and as you remember
the result were intergovernmental
solutions with deep divisions between
member states mainly north and south
this time
with a pandemic's economic crisis
indeed the 27 member states trusted the
european level
with their guarantees they backed the
european commission
to raise capital on the market
and to invest it mainly now two
priorities
the european green deal and
digitalization
we call this huge recovery program of
800 billion euros next generation eu
and this next generation eu includes by
far the largest green bond program ever
we will invest close to 40 of next
generation eu in green projects that's
up to 300 billion euros
and so far
all the bonds we issued
to finance these investments were
heavily oversubscribed
and over one third of our bonds were
bought by investors from outside the
european union
this is a clear sign of confidence
and trust in europe from the rest of the
world
but of course i know we must do more
so public investment alone won't work
miracles unless
they are matched by strong private
investments
europe alone will need to invest an
additional 360 billion euros for
transforming its energy system
every year
that is a staggering figure
yet it is entirely within our reach
but the private sector must come on
board
and governments have to create the
conditions for this to happen
and this is what we have been putting
into place brick by brick by brick
we have now the first ever european
climate law
and that ensures
that our climate targets are not just an
ambition but a legal obligation
we have now proposed a detailed legal
framework
that ensures that we can reduce our
emissions by at least 55 by 2030.
so this is our road map
for the next decade
cast in law
and this provides certainty and trust
for investors
that if they put their money in clean
and climate friendly projects
they can rely on the fact
that policy makers will stay the course
or
take the critical sector of
semiconductors
demand for them is skyrocketing
today we have microchips not only in our
pcs and smartphones but also in our cars
and the heating system of our homes
in our hospitals
in the life-saving ventilators
there is no digital without chips
and the european need for chips will
double in the next decade
and this is why we need to radically
raise europe's game on the development
production and use of this key
technology
europe is strong in some specific areas
such as for example the design of
components for power electronics
or chips for the automotive and
manufacturing industries
europe is the world's center for
semiconductor research
and europe is also very well positioned
in terms of the materials and equipment
that are needed to run large chip
manufacturing plants
but europe's global semiconductors
market share is only 10
and today most of our supplies come from
a handful of producers outside europe
and this is a dependency and uncertainty
we simply cannot afford
so by 2030
20 of the world's microchips production
should be in europe and keep in mind
that the world's production itself will
double so this means quadrupling today's
european
production we have no time to lose
and this is why i can announce here
today
that we will propose our european chips
act
in early february
what does it do
it will help us to make progress
across five areas first
we will strengthen our world-class
research and innovation capacity in
europe
second
we will focus on ensuring european
leadership in design
and manufacturing
thirdly
we will and this is important further
adapt our state aid rules
of course under a set of strict
conditions
but this will allow public support for
the very first time
for european first of a kind
production facilities
so that benefit all of europe
fourthly
we will improve our toolbox box to
anticipate and respond to shortages and
crisis in this sector
to shore up our security of supply so to
be better prepared
and fifth and finally of course we will
support smaller innovative companies
in accessing advanced skills industrial
partners and equity finance
it's a whole big program this european
ships act
but i also want to be clear in this
community
europe will always work to keep global
markets
open and connected
this is in the world's interest and it's
in our own interest
but we also need to tackle the
bottlenecks that slow down our own
growth
because this will help us become a
stronger player
not just in some niche
but throughout the whole value chain
and it is important for us so to
conclude
we will promote diversification among
like-minded partners
we will create more balanced
interdependencies
and we will build supply chains we can
trust
by avoiding
single points of failure
the point is
that there will always be
when we need to address wider issues in
our economies
and look let me look at the second one
today's global energy pressure
is a case in point
we will soon mark 50 years since the
start of the oil crisis in the 1970s
and i guess some of us will remember
vividly the impact of the crisis on our
economy but also in our lives i remember
being on a bicycle on the autobahn
some countries banned indeed the driving
on sundays
to set lower speed limits on the
motorways others
rationed gasoline or told people to hit
only one room in the house
and many of you know the debates it
caused on the limits of growth
now the world is a different place today
and parallels can seem a bit tenuous
but there is a cautionary tale for us
as we face today's gas crisis
and as we have our own debates on the
limits of fossil fuel growth
at the time
our response was not to look at
alternative sources of energy
but rather to look at alternative at
alternative sources of production
so oil exploration spread far and wide
from alaska to siberia from the caspian
sea to the caucasus
the good news is
that we have far more options at our
disposal today
than we did back
then back then less than one percent of
electricity was generated from renewable
sources worldwide
today
this figure has jumped up to close to
one third
today we know much more about the
climate imperative
and today we have the technologies we
need to make the transition from a
fossil fuel system
to a clean energy system
in the short term
we have to address the very real impact
this gas crisis is having on households
and businesses
my commission has put forward a toolbox
of measures that member states are using
to rapidly mitigate the impact of price
rises
but fundamentally
today's gas crisis must serve
to accelerate the transition to clean
energy
it must provide the impetus we need
to further integrate our energy market
and we must ensure that there are no
energy islands or regions of europe that
are cut off from our network
we're working on all these points
but most importantly
we have to manage this necessary
transition carefully
and this comes back to the central
question of trust
because people need to trust
that the transition will support the
most vulnerable
businesses need to trust
that the transition will improve their
competitiveness
and investors need to trust
that we will stay the course
whenever there are bumps on the road
there will never be a linear shift from
a fossil fuel based system
to the clean energy system
we must be upfront about that
but the direction is clear and so is our
commitment
as we respond to this gas crisis
we will focus on protecting those most
affected
we will accelerate the transition
and we will ensure
that we have the reliable suppliers we
need
and this leads me to my last point
that is
trust
in the international arena
at this moment in time the world needs
trust in democracy
as much as between democracies
because tragically we are once again
faced with the interference of some
powers
in the neighbors affairs
we will not go back to the old logic of
competition and spheres of influence
where entire countries were treated as
possessions
or backyards
we have intense days of diplomacy in
different formats with and without
russia
russia has made its proposals
we made our proposals
and it is good
that we engage in dialogue
but we do not accept russia's attempts
to divide europe into spheres of
influence
for us the fundamental principles
underpinning european security remain
valid
in the helsinki final act
and the paris charter both signed by
russia
and we reaffirm our solidarity with
ukraine and our european partners
that are threatened by russia
and of course we continue to stand
behind the fundamental principle
that ukraine is free to decide as a
sovereign state
to be very clear
we want this dialogue
we want conflicts to be solved in the
bodies that have been formed for this
purpose
but if the situation deteriorates
if there are any further attacks on the
territorial integrity of ukraine
we will respond with massive economic
and financial sanctions
the transatlantic community stands firm
on this
the european union is by far russia's
biggest trading partner
and by far the largest investor
and yes this trading relationship is
important to us
but it is far more important to russia
we hope an attack won't happen
but if it does
we are prepared
and what i want us never to forget is
the following
russia and europe share geography
culture
history
we also want a common future
our difficulties are not with russia or
which is its people
our difficulties are with the dangerous
policies of the kremlin
it is the reenactment of familiar
patterns of autocratic behavior
that underscores the old truth
where trust is lacking
force and coercion cannot replace it
and europe's approach is completely
different
we believe that trust and confidence
are more sustainable
than control and coercion
it is the attractiveness of our liberal
democracies that the autocrats fear
our economic success
our civil liberties
and the freedom of speech and ideas
we must step up to defend these most
valuable treasures
of our democracies
again thanks for having me
dear klaus
ladies and gentlemen
and now i'm happy to take your questions
thank you very much
[Music]
you